I want to pick up again now in volume 6 and begin at July 27, 1904. I have a VIP on this
message as well. For one who truly loves God, all things are divine will. There's a huge
statement and everything must be sealed by love. So, Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state,
my adorable Jesus came out from within my interior and holding my head up for I was very tired because
of the long waiting for him. He told me, 'My daughter, one who truly loves me in anything that
happens to her internal and external devours everything as one single thing which is the divine
will so that for someone who truly loves him, everything is taken up into divine will. Of all
things, none seem strange to her as she looks at it as a product of the divine will. Therefore,
she consumes everything in the divine will so her centre, her aim is only and solely the will of
God. She always goes around within the divine will as though inside a ring without ever finding
the way out and making of the divine will her continuous food. So, the divine will is here pictured
as a ring and you're inside of this space and you cannot get out of it because it's eternal and
it's infinite. So, to be in there is already to experience paradise on earth." Later Jesus came
back and told Louisa, "Daughter, let everything in you be sealed by love." To put it very simply,
everything is about love. Everything is about love. God is love, 1 John 4 7. The description of love
is given in 1 Corinthians 13 verses 1 to 13 and then 1 Corinthians 14 1 says you must want love
more than anything else. You also have Matthew 22 verses 37 to 40 where Jesus says that the two
great laws that summarise the entire scriptures is love. Then we have Ephesians 3 verses 16 to 21
that we must be founded on love, grow in love, be built on love and reach the fullness of love.
And you also have John 13 34 to 35 and that is that you must love one another in the same way
as I loved you. That is divinely as well as humanly. Okay? And you have John 15 9. That is as the
Father has loved me so I have loved you and in the same way you are to love one another. So it's all
about love. The only baggage we're allowed when we leave this earth and take our flight to heaven,
the only baggage permitted if you're going to heaven is love. Everything else is not needed,
you have to leave it behind. Okay? So later Jesus came back and he told me daughter let everything
in you be sealed by love. That is all your thoughts, all your words, all your motivations,
all your actions, everything. If you think you must only think of love, if you speak, if you work,
if you palpitate, if you desire, if even just one desire is not love coming out of you, restricted
within yourself, convert everything into love. In other words, if something inside of you
doesn't want to be love, you've got to deal with it inside and what comes out of you is love because
the decision is to love and so we have to battle with any contrary idea that comes to us because
the only thing that we're allowed to think say or do is love if we want this great gift of living
in the divine will. So if something that inside of you is not love, you must restrict it and you
must convert it into love and then give it the freedom to go out only then. And while saying this,
he seemed to be touching my whole person with his hand placing many seals of love. Now to convert
everything into love means that we reign in life with Christ and that's Romans 5 17.
Okay. And this whole thing of transforming everything into love simplifies life hugely.
You accept things as expressing God's will or God's expressed will or God's promissive will,
but for your good. And so you stop having the problems that other people have when they are
living and thinking in a worldly way. So that message requires a good lot of thinking.
July the 28th, 1904. The soul who is detached from everything finds God in all things.
Now notice the connection. If we are detached from the earth and detached from ourselves and
from everything else, we will find God. If we are not detached, we won't find him because
there's stuff blocking it. This morning as I was in my usual state, Louisa said, "Blessed Jesus
came for just a little." And he told me, my daughter, when the soul is detached from everything,
that is free, that you're not bound, you're not enslaved by anything. When the soul is detached
and free from everything in all things, then she finds God. There's nothing blocking the way.
She finds him within herself. She finds him outside of herself. And she finds him in others,
in other people. So it can be said that the soul who is completely detached
for a soul that is completely detached, all things convert or change into God. That's the most
amazing reality. And it's what we are asked to move towards.
Even more, she not only finds God but contemplates him, feels him, embraces him.
And since she finds him in everything, all things administer to her
and occasion to adore him, to pray to him, to thank him, to draw close to him more intimately,
and therefore she is growing constantly, momentarily, every hour in holiness.
And besides, your lament about my privation, the Lord said, are not completely reasonable
because he's explained to her over and over that the privations are because he needs to chastise
and he needs to deal with the problems that are upon the earth, because after all he is king and
Lord, he must deal with everything. If you feel me in your interior, he said, it's a sign that I'm
not only outside of you, but also inside as though in my own center. Now, Louisa continuously acknowledges
that he comes out from her center. But that's not what she's looking for. She has been spoiled
and she has seen him in the flesh so often that, unless she sees him that way, she absolutely grieves.
So look what he said, if you feel me in your interior, it is a sign that I'm not only outside
of you, but also inside as though in my own center, that means in my own tabernacle.
I want to give you one Corinthians 3 16 there. No, you not that you are the temple of the living
God and God dwells in you. Then she said, I forgot to say at the beginning that the queen mother
brought Jesus to me. And since I was praying him to content me and not to leave me without himself,
blessed Jesus answered in the way that's given above. So we have another VIP message now on
July the 29th, 1904, in which the Lord tells us that trust is absolutely vital in our relationship
with God. You know that trust is basic to every real relationship. And it's basic to our relationship
with God as well. The more we trust him, the more the relationship is on a solid footing.
Saint Therese of Lissue was very strong about this. And she says that we will get from God
only what we have confidence to receive. That confidence is that childlike trust in him.
So faith, the heading here is faith makes one know God, but trust makes one find him.
So it's the difference between simply just knowledge in your head and the reality of
actually finding him. So continue in my usual state, Louisa said, as soon as I saw my adorable
Jesus, I said to him, my Lord and my God. And he continued God, God, God alone, daughter,
faith makes one know God, but trust makes one find him. So without trust, faith is sterile.
You might end up just with doctrines, but never knowing him personally. Faith is sterile. And
even though faith possesses immense riches with which the soul can enrich herself,
if there's no trust, she remains always poor and lacking in everything.
While he was saying this, I felt myself being drawn into God, and I remained absorbed in him
like a little drop of water in the immense sea. Now here's a little bit of what is essential
in these writings. And that is my nothingness thrown into his allness. And my nothingness in the
immense sea of his love is the reality that we're supposed to be living.
As I looked, she said, I could find no boundaries, either of height or of depth, heaven and earth,
blessed and pilgrim souls that were all immersed in this sea that we're calling God.
I could also see wars, she said, like that between Russia and Japan, and thousands of soldiers who
are dying and will die. And that by justice, also natural justice, the victory should be with Japan.
And I saw that other European nations are plotting machinations of war even against nations of Europe.
This is 1904, and this is the plans for World War I. But who can say all that I could see of God
and in God? Now notice that looking at God, you see all reality. This is where the prophets and the
saints were able to tell us things about the future, because once they could really see God,
they could see the reality that was going on on the earth as well. So I want to give you Amos 3-7,
and that God never does anything without telling the prophets first. But it's important for us
to recognize that when we truly contemplate God, we see reality as it really is, both in heaven
and on earth. So July the 30th, 1904, is speaking about the detachment that priests ought to have.
So this morning, Blessed Jesus was not coming, and at Louisa said, "And I finding myself outside of
myself went round and round and search of my highest good." Now that's the bride looking for the bride
groom in Song of Songs, Chapter 3, Verses 1-2. "And not finding him my soul felt dying at each instant,
but what increased my torment was that while I felt I was dying, I would not die. For if I could
die, I would reach my intent to be forever with my center, which is God." Put beside that two
Corinthians 5, 1-10, "You may desire to be with God, but you need to choose to remain on the earth
for as long as God wants." "Or separation how bitter and painful you are," she said.
"There's no pain that can be compared to you. Or divine privation, you consume, you pierce.
You are a two-edged sword that cuts on one side and burns on the other. The pain you give is immense,
as immense as is God himself, which means infinite." Now while wandering around,
"I found myself in purgatory," Louisa said, "and my sorrow and my crying seemed to increase the sorrow
of those poor souls deprived of their life, which is God." The main agony of purgatory, of course,
is that they have seen God and they desperately need him just as Louisa has seen him and desperately
needs him. So the pain she experiences is what we call purgatory. Among the souls in purgatory,
there seemed to be quite a few priests, one of whom seemed to be suffering more than the others
and he said to me, "My grave sufferings come from the fact that in life I was very attached to family
interests and to earthly things, and I had a little attachment to some people." Now this soul is talking
about is that one of the problems in the church in Italy at this time, 1904, was that families used
to give their business to their sons who were priests, because everybody would trust the priest
as being someone who was trustworthy, whereas they wouldn't trust one another in economy and in
business. And so it actually drew the priest away from the holiness of his office and got him involved
in business matters that he shouldn't be involved in. And so that's what this soul is talking about.
I got very attached to family interests and earthly things and I had a little attachment to
some people. This produces so much evil for the priest as to form an iron shell covered with mud
that in wraps him like a garment and only the fire of purgatory and the fire of the privation
of God, this is what Louisa needs to learn, which is such that compared to it the first fire disappears
can destroy this shell. Now the Lord is allowing Louisa to hear this from this priest so that she
can hear that the pain of her privation is the most precious of her pains that she can offer to the
Lord to release souls from purgatory and to save souls as well. The priest said, "Oh how much I
suffer, my pains are unutterable. Pray, pray for me." I felt even more tormented and I found myself
inside of myself, Louisa said. In other words, he spoke to her about the pain of privation. Later,
I saw just the shadow of blessed Jesus and he told me, "My daughter, what were you searching for?
For you, there are no other reliefs and helps but me alone because she's a victim soul. She has this
absolutely privileged special relationship with God and there is nobody else that she can turn to.
Nobody can relieve her." He disappeared like a flash and I was left saying, "Ah, he himself
tells me this, that he alone is everything for me and yet he has the courage to leave me without
deprived of him." So the pain of the privation is so great that she keeps forgetting that if she
offers it, it will be an incredible leverage in her intercession. We now come to July the 31st
1904 and this is a very important message about the problems of the human will. I've been saying to
you that if we do not put the human will aside, the divine will cannot take over. It's as simple as
that. So the heading is that the human will falsifies and profanes even the holiest works.
You have to put a VIP on this and multiply it by about 10. Continuing in my poor state, Louisa says,
"It seemed that he came more than once and I seemed to see him as a child as though surrounded
by a shadow. He said to me, 'My daughter, don't you feel the freshness of my shadow? Rest in it,
for you will find refreshment.' And it seemed that we rested together in his shadow and I felt all
reinvigorated being close to him." Okay, so I want to give you a few references for the shadow
of his wings. That is Psalm 17 verse 8, Psalm 36 verse 7, Psalm 57 verse 1, Psalm 63 verse 7,
et cetera, et cetera. Okay, the shadow of his wings is one of the great images of the Bible.
His shadow and I, sorry, when we rested together in his shadow, I felt reinvigorated being close to
him. Then he continued, "My beloved, if you love me, I do not want you to look either inside or
outside of yourself at whether you are warm or cold, whether you do much or you do little
or whether you suffer or you enjoy. All this must be destroyed in you. In other words,
don't look at yourself at all. Let God take care of you and you surrender completely moment by
moment to the will of God as revealed to you." The other ways, that is the other ways of living
a spiritual life, as high and sublime and industrious as they may be, as 2 Corinthians 4, 16 to 18,
2 Corinthians 4, 16 to 18. So the other ways, as high and sublime and industrious as they may,
cannot please me and they cannot content my love. Oh, how many souls falsify true devotion
and profane the holiest works with their own will, always seeking themselves. Now, this is something
that is so vital, I have to illustrate it for you. I've given retreats for about 45 years in
different countries and the people who come under retreats are people who are really seeking God.
They're the holy ones. They're the daily mascars. They're the ones who are doing the adoration.
They're the ones who want to grow in holiness. But the strange thing is when they come to the
retreat house, they want the best rooms. They want all the luxury they can get. They want the best
food. They want the best seats in the synagogue. They want all kinds of luxuries and they will
complain if the food isn't fantastic and they will complain if the room isn't first class.
What are we seeking ourselves or God? I've always been scandalized by this
and also amazed as well. So another illustration would be that you find people who seem to be
very fervent in their prayer and they'll spend hours in prayer when prayer is easy for them.
But when prayer becomes difficult, oh, they won't be around because they're only finding their own
satisfaction in the prayer. Now, as long as the human will is being satisfied, we're not surrendering
at all to the divine will. And so this is the basic thing in our journey into the divine will,
that if we do not put the human will aside, the divine will cannot take over. It's actually that
simple. So Jesus continues even in holy things, if one seeks her own way and her own taste and the
satisfaction of herself, if she finds herself, she escapes from God and does not find him.
Now, one of the things is very, very common in our churches is that people demand to sit in the
same place all the time. And if you accidentally went into that place, you would find whether
they were seeking God or not. I have been very strongly pushed out of particular places that I
accidentally went into because it was my first time in the church. And you find that while this
person appears to be coming to seek God, in actual fact, the human will is seeking all the
satisfaction it can get. So I want to give you Matthew 10, 39, and Matthew 16, 25. Okay. So,
now we come to August the 4th, 1904. The state of the blessed in heaven will be according to the
ways in which they comported themselves with God on earth. So you need to put a VIP on this.
It's how we behave on earth that determines where we go in heaven and if we go to heaven.
In other words, the ball is entirely in our court.
So this morning, when blessed Jesus came, Louisa said, he transported me outside of myself
and taking me by the hand, he led me as far as underneath the vault of the heavens.
Now, I've said before in these writings that Louisa is confined to a bed day in day out,
year in year out. And the Lord balances that very confined experience by taking her
soul in and out of the body experience to let her experience the full expanse of the heavens.
And he brings her around the earth. He takes her in all kinds of places so that she's
not confined in the way that would look, if you only look at her physically.
So it went as far as the vault of the heavens from where one could see the blessed and hear
their chanting. Oh, how blessed, how the blessed were swimming in God.
One could see their lives in God and the life of God in them. So you see that at this level,
in this experience that Louisa has spiritual vision, which is incredible.
And so she can see things that on the earth are absolutely unavailable to us.
One could see their lives in God and the life of God in them. This alone seems to me to be the
whole essence of their happiness. So it's their union with God that creates their heaven.
It also seems to me that each of the blessed is a new heaven in that blessed dwelling.
Because you remember John 14 verses one to two in my father's house, there are many mentions,
and there's one for you. So each one of them has what we would call a mansion, she says,
and you have it in that blessed dwelling. But they're all distinct among themselves.
There's no one similar to anybody else. Now look at this very carefully because it means
that each one of us is expected to bring back to heaven some unique testimony about God.
And we get this unique testimony by our own personal experience of God. And nobody else ever
will have that total experience but you. And so if we don't take that testimony back, heaven is
lacking that particular stroke of the brush. There's no one similar to anybody else. And this happens
according to the ways in which they comported themselves with God on the earth. One tried to love
him more and he will love him more in heaven and will receive from God every new and increasing
love in such a way that this heaven will have a divine shade and feature which is all special
to that love. Another tried to glorify him more and blessed God will give him an ever-increasing
glory in such a way that this new heaven will be more glorious and glorified by the very divine
glory and so on with all the other distinct ways in which the saints actually wanted to serve him.
And so it can be said she said that what we do for God on earth we will continue in heaven.
That's very very interesting. So I want to give you one Corinthians 3 verses 11 to 15.
What we do for God on earth we shall continue in heaven but with greater perfection.
Therefore the good we do is not temporary but will last for eternity and will shine before God
and around us continuously to Corinthians 3 verses 1 to 3.
Louisa continues, oh how happy we will be in seeing that all our good and the glory we give to God
as well as our own comes from that little bit of good that we started imperfectly in heaven.
Now in Paul's letter to the Romans chapter 8 he says that the little bit of suffering we get in
this earth cannot be compared to the glory that God gives to us in heaven which is out of all
proportion to what we suffered for him on the earth. If all could see this she said oh how they
would hasten to love more to praise to thank and to do other things for the Lord so as to be able
to do it with greater intensity in heaven. But who can say everything? Rather it seems to me that
I'm speaking a lot of nonsense about this blessed dwelling place. She uses that expression when she
says I'm not sure if I'm communicating. My mind has it in one way but my mouth cannot find the
words that's 1 Corinthians 2-9 that the things that God has prepared for those who love him are
beyond what the mind can cope with, what the eyes can see and the heart can understand.
Then afterwards the Lord transported me to earth she says, oh how horrifying are the troubles on
the earth in these sad times. Yet it seems that this is still nothing to compare to what is to come
both in the religious state so much so that it seems that the church this good and holy mother
will be torn to shreds by her very children. Here again you need to put Amos 3-7 God is showing
her something ahead of time and the wreckage that we see in the church today is what she's looking
at. It didn't begin today we are experiencing the very bitter fruits of what was produced
in the 20th century. She said and yet it seems this is still nothing compared to what will come
both in the religious state so much so that it seems that the church this good and holy mother
will be torn to shreds by her very children and also in the secular state so in the political as
well as religious spheres. Then after this he took me back into myself and told me tell me a
little bit my daughter how am I for you and Louisa said you are everything for me nothing enters
into me everything flows outside but you alone and he said and I am all all for you that's the
marvelous exchange oh at Mirabbile Commertium is what the church used to say in Latin what an
incredible exchange that we give ourselves to God and God gives himself fully to us so that's
Deuteronomy 6 verses 4 to 10. So he said and I am all for you nothing of you goes out of me
and I delight all of myself in you so from the very way I am with you you can see how you are
with me and he disappeared leaving her to think about that. So August the 5th 1904 Jesus is the
ruler of kings and the lord of lords okay he is Adon Adonim that is lord of lords and Malek
Malekim king of kings I've given you the Hebrew words so I want to give you Revelation 17 4 where
that is declared that he's king of kings and lord of lords. Continue in my usual state blessed Jesus
came for just a little in the act of ruling and dominating everything and of reigning with the crown
of a king on his head and with the scepter of command in his hand you remember at john 19 when
Pilate said are you a king and Jesus said yes I am but I'm not a king of this world which of course
left Pilate completely not understanding. While I was seeing him in this position he told me though
in latin but I will say it according to what I understand she said my daughter I am the ruler
of kings and the lord of lords so I want to give you one Timothy 615 and Revelation 19 16 where this
is declared to be alone is this right of justice Jew which the soul owes me and by not giving it to
me she denies me as creator and master of everything you see we're the only creatures in the universe
who have free will and therefore we're the only ones who can actually deny something to god
and we have a much greater responsibility than all other creatures to actually give god what he's
looking for. So if she denies me as creator and master of everything while saying this he seemed
to take the world in his hand and turn it upside down so that human creatures would submit to his
regime and dominion now turning it upside down of course is allowing incredible disasters to happen
to try and shake us up. At the same time I could see how the lord ruled and dominated in my soul
Luke 17 21 with such mastery that I felt all submerged in him from him came the rule of my mind of my
infections of my desires many electric wires passed between me and him through which he directed
and dominated everything in other words in louise he was in fact lord many people sing he is lord he
is lord but they don't allow him to actually rule in them as lord. So august the sixth 1904
the privation is a pain of fire that ignites consumes annihilates and its purposes to destroy
human life and constitute divine so now we're going to be talking about this privation that is
worrying louisa very much. This morning I went through the most bitter time because of the
privation of my highest and only good louisa says the sorrow of the privation was such
that I as I found myself outside of myself the pain of my soul was so great that the pain itself
administered such strength to it that it wanted to destroy whatever it found as hindrance to finding
its all who is god. So here you have something that only the victim souls and people who have
been really graced to suffer can actually testify to us the rest of us have to take it as it is
said to us and that is that when a person suffers this deep deep deep pain in their innermost being
while it is awful suffering at the same time it gives immense strength or fortitude to the soul.
So I want to give you sam 63 and sam 42 there
and then louisa said and not finding him now she's in and out of the body experience
the soul would shout and cry and run more than the wind it wanted to upset everything to turn
everything upside down in order to find the life that it was lacking oh privation how intense is
your bitterness she says your sorrow is always new and because it is new the soul feels the bitterness
of the pain as ever new my soul feels as if one whole flesh would separate into many shreds and
all those shreds with justice ask for their life and we'll find it only when they find god
now here you've got a pain that most of us have no comprehension of at all but the souls in purgatory
would understand because it is pain like their pain but who can say the state that I am in
meanwhile angels saints and purging souls rushed up to me placing themselves in a circle around me
and preventing me from running sympathizing with me and assisting me but everything was useless for
me because in them I could not find the one who alone could soothe my pain and restore my life
and so I shouted more crying out tell me where can I find him as the song of songs chapter 3
verses 1 to 4 and louisa is illustrating what saint risa of avalanche told us that god alone
suffice it the only the only person who can actually bring us to a place of peace and calm and rest
is god alone nobody else and nothing else and so louisa said to them if you want to have pity on me
do not delay showing him to me and for I can take no more then after this he came out from within
the depth of my soul he's there all the time but she she has this desperate need to see him
outside of herself and to see him full bodied as we would say
and it seemed that he pretended to be sleeping while being concerned about the hardness of my
without being concerned about the difficulty of my poor state but even though he would not bother
and was sleeping at merely seeing him I breathed my life as one breeds air
ah here he is with me however I was not freed of the pain in seeing that he would not even pay
attention to me and so love demands a response of love from the beloved then after much suffering
as if he had awakened he said my daughter all other tribulations can be penances
expiations compensations but only the privation
of the lord is a pain of fire that ignites consumes annihilates and does not give up
until the human life is destroyed the human life means the human will
but while it consumes it also vivifies and it constitutes divine life in it so she's being consumed
by divine love and she just needs to understand what's actually going on that's Hebrews 12-29
Matthew 3-11 also says that the Holy Spirit is fire and that we have to be baptized with this fire
that will consume us and make us ready for the divine fire which is heaven
August the seventh 1904 the first to persecute the church will be religious the religious ones
okay
as I was in my usual state Louisa said I found myself surrounded by angels and saints who said to me
it's necessary that you suffer more for the imminent things that are about to happen against
the church now at the time that this message is given the communists have already begun
infiltrating the church to do the most devastating damage to it that we're still suffering from today
and the communists will be followed by the Freemasons who will make it even worse
and because Satan had asked for a hundred years to destroy the church and he was given permission
why would he be given permission it's because that hundred years was a test
and the church should have been able to respond and should have been able to pass the test
and grow in holiness and glorify God actual fact the church seems to be disintegrating
and I mean the church in all its denominations
and so the angels and the saints said to Louisa it's necessary that you suffer more for the
imminent things that are about to happen against the church for if they do not come about immediately
time will make them happen in a milder way and with less offense to God
so if Louisa suffers for them again it won't be as terrible as it might have been
and Louisa said is suffering perhaps in my power if the Lord gives it to me I will gladly suffer
meanwhile they took me and brought me for the throne of our Lord and they prayed together that
he would make me suffer and blessed Jesus coming towards us in the form of the crucified shared
his pains with me now notice it's the angels and the saints that are interceding that the terrifying
attack that was going to come to the church would be less and that their their interest
and their intercession for us in heaven is something we need to take note of
so Jesus accepts the prayer and intercession of the saints in heaven for the pilgrim souls on earth
afterwards Jesus said to me my daughter sufferings divert my just indignation
and the light of grace is renewed in human minds that's what is produced by this
voluntary suffering of Louisa and that is that grace is given to people and therefore
an opportunity to change and to convert and come back to God and stop the disaster
our daughter Jesus said do you think that it will be the lay people who will be the first to
persecute the church now they say secular I'm saying lay it's probably you mean the people who are
outside the church the political and social sphere that he's actually talking about do you think
the world we would say will persecute the church uh he said no it will be the religious the very
leaders who pretending to be sons and shepherds while in reality they are poisonous snakes
that poisoned themselves and others will begin among themselves to lacerate this good mother
and then they laity or the people outside the society will follow and this is happening as we're
speaking the disasters that is happening the church as a result of all this sexual deviation
and all the crimes that have been committed this will be followed by persecution as the night follows
day and so the sexual side of it wasn't the beginning the beginning was rationalism humanism
modernism secularism okay and so Jesus says in Matthew 7 15 that some leaders are wolves
in sheep's clothing unfortunately we have some today
and then luisa finishes this by saying obedience called me and the lord withdrew okay
so august the 8th 1904 I have a VIP on this one as well the soul must look for Jesus within
herself not outside now poor luisa has Jesus all the time inside she's always looking outside
and if you remember the confessions of saint Augustine he said I looked for you outside
and you were within okay Jesus of course said in the in the gospel that the kingdom of God is within
us Luke 17 21 while I continued struggling luisa said my adorable Jesus came for just a little
but even though I felt him near me I would try to grab him and he would escape almost preventing
me from going outside of myself to go and search of him then after I struggled very much he made
himself seen for just a little and told me my daughter do not look for me outside of yourself
but within yourself in the depth of your soul because that's where the kingdom of God is because
if you go outside and do not find me you will suffer very much and will not be able to endure
if you can find me more easily why do you want to struggle more and luisa said
it's because I believe that not finding you immediately within myself I can find you outside
it's love that pushes me to do this and Jesus said ah it's love that pushes you to do this
everything everything should be enclosed in one single word love one john four seven God is love
Ephesians 3 16 21 you must grow to full maturity in love one Corinthians 14 one you must want love
more than anything else and then Sam one four five verse 17 God only ever acts out of love
a summary of the 36 volumes of louisa picaretta is this divine will and love why is that because
God who is the divine will is love the divine will is the operating part of the blessed trinity
but the reality of the nature of the blessed trinity is that it is love so if we're not growing in love
we're not growing in divine will if we are growing in love we're growing in divine will
ah he said everything everything should be enclosed in one single word love
if the soul does not enclose everything in this it can be said that she does not know a thing
about loving me and according to how much the soul loves me do I expand the gift of suffering
notice the gift of suffering most of us don't want to think of suffering as a gift
so louisa interrupting Jesus all surprised and afflicted said my life and my whole good she said
so since I suffer little or nothing I love you little or not at all what fright the mere thought
that I do not love you my soul feels a sharp disappointment and I almost feel offended by you
and he added I do not intend to disappoint you your disappointment would press on my heart
more than your own and besides you must not look at the mere corporal sufferings but also at the
spiritual sufferings and at the true will you have to suffer you see many people don't have
a physical sufferings on the outside but they can be suffering dreadfully mentally and emotionally
and spiritually all three or even one of them and sometimes in the spiritual life you have
spiritual suffering that has no name and we we just don't know why we're suffering so deeply inside
and it's because the Lord is actually purifying us besides he said do not look at the mere corporal
sufferings but also at the spiritual and at the true will you have to suffer because if the soul
truly wants to suffer for me it is as if the soul has done it that's terribly important statement
if you truly want to love the Lord then as far as he's concerned you have loved him if you do
something and you want to do it for him as far as he's concerned it is done for him therefore
calm yourself and do not be troubled and let me continue speaking now notice that Jesus says here
and he has said it before that the intention is accepted as the accomplished deed this is very very
important he said haven't you ever seen two intimate friends or how they try to imitate each other
and to reproduce the other within themselves they imitate the voice the manners the steps the
works that close in such a way as the friend can say the one who loves me is another me and since
he is me I cannot help loving him we see this very much with the youth culture imitating their
football fans or their actors and actresses that they want to imitate he said that's what I do
with the soul who encloses all of me within herself as though within a small circle of love
and when he says that all of him can be reflected in us within a small circle of love
think of a drop of water reflecting the whole sky the whole sky can be reflected there but the
drop of water is infinitely smaller and so in the same way the Lord can reflect himself in us even
though we are infinitely small I feel as though reproduced within her he said and finding myself
I love her with all my heart and I cannot do without being with her because if I leave her
I would leave myself so what Jesus is talking about there is this oneness that you have in John
14 20 to 21 I will dwell in you and you will dwell in me both of us will be completely one
and so this is the reality that is there for us in union with God
notice you can't really have the divine will without union with God
so August the 9th 1904 this is a very important message about obedience as essential in the divine
will it's not the works that constitute the merit of man it's obedience alone this is very
important so it's not the suffering that louisa is doing it's the fact that it's an obedience to
the divine will that whatever we do is an obedience to the divine will after delaying Jesus came for
just a little like a bolt of light one John one five God is light and I was left filled with this
light inside and out I am unable to say what my soul understood and experienced within this light
I will only say that afterwards blessed Jesus told me my daughter it's not the works that constitute
the merit of man what is it's the obedience to divine will alone that constitute all merits
as a birth from the divine will in other words if it comes from the divine will Jesus calls a
birth from the divine will so much so that everything I did and suffered in the course of my life
everything was a birth from the will of God now many times I have given you John's gospel
John 5 37 16 8 28 29 8 55 10 29 38 12 50 14 31 this is all a summary of John's gospel and
it ends with this marvelous statement in John 14 31 I want the world to know that I love the
father and therefore I do exactly as my father tells me now Jesus also said in the gospel
if you love me you will keep my word and therefore we have to show our love to Jesus
by actually obeying his commandments by actually fulfilling his word by letting it become reality
in us okay so Jesus said everything in my life was a birth from the will of the father this is why
my merits are innumerable because they are constituted by divine obedience and therefore
they are infinite merits therefore I do not look so much the multiplicity and greatness of the works
but at the connection that they have either directly with divine obedience or indirectly
with obedience to one who represents me so there's no way out of this for each one of us
no way at all if if that obedience isn't there then we are not living divine will it's that simple
so let's go on to August the 10th 1904 God knows the number the value and the weight
of all created things now for that I want to give you Sam 139 you know my thoughts before I think
them my words before I say them this is too wonderful for me I want to give you Matthew 10 30 as well
as I was in my usual state Louisa said I found myself wandering around churches there she is
sitting in her bed apparently totally confined but her soul is out of her body and she's wandering
around the churches making a pilgrimage to Jesus in the most holy Eucharist together with my
guards in angel in one of the churches I said prisoner of love you are here abandoned and alone
and I have come to keep you company and while keeping you company I intend now notice the intention
the placing of the intention is extremely important I intend to love you for those who offend you
praise you for those who despise you thank you for those in whom you pour graces but do not render
you the tribute of thanksgiving I want to console you for those who afflict you and repair for any
offense against you in a word I intend to do for you all that others are obliged to do for you
for having remained in the most holy sacrament and I also intend to repeat this for as many drops of
water for as many fish and grains of sand in the seashore so here she's multiplying the prayer
we can do this very simply by just simply saying lord I multiply this to the infinite
while I was saying this all the waters of the sea became present before my mind
and I said within myself my sight cannot grasp the whole vastness of the sea nor does it know the
depth and weight of those immense waters but the lord knows he knows their number their weight
and their measure and I stayed there quite marveling at that moment blessed Jesus told me silly
silly that you are why do you marvel so much what is difficult and impossible for the creature
is easy and possible and also natural for the creator now that's repeated quite a number of
times in scripture I going to give you Luke 138 nothing is impossible with god Matthew 19 26
again nothing is impossible with god all things are possible for him it happens in this as to someone
who looking at millions and millions of coins in the twinkling of an eye says they are innumerable
who can count them but the one who put them in that place tells everything in one word
they are this many they are worth this much and they weigh that amount my daughter I know
how many drops of water I myself put into the sea and no one can disperse even a single one of them
I numbered everything I weighed everything I evaluated everything and so with everything else
he's also told us that he has counted the hairs on our heads
so what is the marble if I know everything god is omniscient
and not only is he omniscient he's omnipotent he can do anything on hearing this every marvel
ceased or rather I marveled at my silliness she said and we need to realize that you know after all
this length of history we have discovered in the third millennium after christ that there's
approximately 100 billion galacties in the sky and growing so we'll never know the number of things
and there's billions of stars in each one of these galacties so the number is known only to god
he needs to keep some things for himself I think don't you let's do one more
august 12th 1904 man disperses the beauty with which god created him
as I continued struggling all of a sudden I found all of myself inside the lord
and from his head a shining thread descended into mine which bound me completely inside of Jesus
oh how happy I was to be inside of him as much as I looked I could see nothing but him alone
this is my highest happiness only Jesus him alone and nothing else oh how well one feels
meanwhile he told me courage my daughter don't you see how the thread of my will binds you completely
inside of me so if any other will wants to bind you if it is not holy it cannot
because since you are inside of me if it is not holy it cannot enter into me so I want to give you
Leviticus 19 2 and Hebrews 12 14 and I'll give you a few more in a minute and while saying this he
looked at me over and over again and then he added I created the soul with a rare beauty
I endowed her with a light superior to any other created light and yet man disperses this beauty
inside of ugliness and this light inside of darkness I want to give you 1 Peter 1 15 to 16
I want to give you Revelation 21 27 and one Corinthians 3 17 for the temple of God is holy
and we leave it there for now